hey Becca hey Kim so in this video we're
going to continue talking about how this
arbitrary racial hierarchy was
established in America specifically
about the beginning of the Atlantic
slave trade and how our society became
so stratified by race so early on okay
interesting the Portuguese had started
to buy slaves and bring them to Europe
as early as fifteen twenty six but
wasn't until the 1600s when slaves were
transported across the Atlantic and sold
into servitude in the new colonies
alright so I'm going to draw us a little
antic world here so we and please
forgive my terrible Maps woman ship this
was directly connected to this
competition between European powers for
a stronghold in the New World
so this began with the Spanish in 1492
with Christopher Columbus but slowly
also the English the Dutch the
Portuguese everyone is trying to
establish their own colony that they
could hopefully gain a lot of new
resources from and just established
glory really in this new world and
having slaves was a really big part of
being able to do that yeah I mean if you
think about just imagine kind of living
in I don't know England's and hearing
about how well Spain is doing getting
all this gold and silver from the new
world so Spain is definitely improving
its national standing in Europe and the
rest of Europe is thinking mmm sounds to
me like we need to get in on this game
and so to get in on the game really what
the European powers needed were laborers
to work in these new plantations as you
may know when the Europeans came over
they brought a ton of disease which
decimated these Native American
populations which they had previously
used to labor through the in commanda
system so the African slaves actually
had immunities to these diseases that
the European powers really wanted to
capitalize upon yeah I think what's
interesting here and the reason that I
do
this map is because I think it really
helps us understand why it was that
people who lived over here had no
immunity to European disease and why
people who lived over here did because
if you think about sailing
so here's Europe and people had been
trading with Europe and West Africa and
into the Middle East here for hundreds
of years
exactly so that gave them plenty of time
to kind of build up immunities to each
other so not only do people in Africa
have the immunity to disease they're
also kind of a readily available labor
source because the practice of taking
prisoners of war and selling them as
slaves on the west coast of Africa was
already established so Europeans are
looking for a labor force it isn't going
to die of disease and there are people
being sold as slaves on the west coast
of Africa already so at this point there
are kind of two competing labor forces
between the Native Americans and the
African slaves colonists start realizing
that the African slaves are actually a
more economical labor force than the
Native Americans since they had this
immunity right and they're also easier
to keep as slaves for Europeans because
they're not on their home territory you
know if someone showed up to your town
and said you're my slave now you're
going to run away to the hills and they
don't know anything about where your
town is so you're fine right it's hard
to enslave people on their home
territory but if you are buying someone
who has been wrestled away from their
home in central Africa brought to the
coast there with people who don't even
speak the same language as them they're
put on a ship to the new world which is
incredibly deadly say probably about 30%
of enslaved Africans who were put in
this what is called the Middle Passage
out died during the voyage I think
that's a really good point and the
reason that some colonists actually
preferred native-american slaves is
because of their knowledge of the land
and agriculture so the subordination of
both Native Americans the African slaves
led to lots of intermarriage between the
two groups and so in the colony as there
became a sense of racial mixing that we
had never seen before interesting and
and I can see how this may pose a
problem if you're trying to figure out
who should be a slave and who should not
because if you have someone who belongs
to both groups where do you categorize
them so a lot of the Spanish that were
coming over had trouble distinguishing
so who was supposed to be a slave and
who was a Native American as these two
groups intermarried so let's check out
this painting to learn a little bit more
about how the different groups were
mixing at the time and how racial
hierarchy really solidified at this time
period so you can definitely see that
they put things in in multiple layers
here here's Virgin Mary
sort of representation of God or the
higher power and then here you see the
Spanish whites and below that Native
Americans who might be the offspring of
white Spanish settlers and Native
Americans a Spanish and a Native
American that was called mestizos right
right or they might be the offspring of
a Native American and an African and
those people refer to as Creoles so
there's a very complex system of racial
hierarchy in this Spanish society
basically organized around how much
white blood a person had the more
privileges and rights you had in their
society and you see the inverse in early
America right in the early 1800s when
even one drop of African blood would
make a person a slave right and that's
one thing that is always very confusing
even to the people of the time period
because it would be possible for someone
who looked quite light-skinned to still
be enslaved by virtue of their parentage
exactly and so this is the system by
which society in the early colonial time
period was organized around a completely
arbitrary factor like race it was simply
the easiest way to identify people and
create a working class and you know as
we move forward as the English begin to
settle North America and shortly after
their settlement import African slaves
the United States will become heir to a
version of this system